c'est non non bonjour je donne c'était
qu'il n'a pas très longue es-tu là un
petit peu resserré nous entrons en vif
du sujet pierre desproges en 87 à
bourges voici son texte je serais bref
rassurez-vous comme je sais lettres
chaque fois que je m'estime sous payés
par rapport à l'ampleur de la tâche qui
m'incombe
et croyez-le mesdames et messieurs elle
est rude pour moi cette tâche
quoi de plus difficile en effet pour un
homme de mon faible gabarit que d'avoir
à s'exprimer haut et fort sur un sujet
qu'ils emmerdent devant des gens qui ne
sont pas de son milieu je vous le dis
comme je le pense personne n'était moins
désignées que moi pour prendre la parole
ici ce soir
en effet mesdames et messieurs le
printemps de bourges j'en ai rien à
secouer
je hais le rock je conchie la musique
classique le jazz mais rate et jane
birkin commence à nous les gonfler avec
ses regard désolé de meroux au bord des
larmes quand un humoriste français qui
ont survécu à l'hécatombe de 1986 au
cours de laquelle deux employés de paul
lederman sont tombés coup sur coup et je
pèse mes mots quand un humoriste
français dit je dois à l'honnêteté de
reconnaître qu'il y en a plus en france
ce ne sont pas michel leeb et stéphane
collaro qui me contrediront sur ce point
on me dira que j'exagère bien sûr
raymond devos et louis leprince-ringuet
font toujours pouffer les rigolard du
troisième âge mais pour combien de temps
encore
comme vous mesdames et messieurs j'ai
reçu de dossier de presse de ce énième
printemps de bourges c'est avec
consternation que j'ai pris connaissance
du programme des réjouissances qui vont
se dérouler chez les bouseux berrichon
pendant dix jours du 17 au 26 avril
prochain le croirez-vous en dehors du
mien aucun des noms d'artistes tous
azimuts qui défilait sous mes yeux
ébahis ne m'était familier est il
possible me disait jean mon for
intérieur est il possible qu'en dehors
de pierre desproges qui se donnera en
spectacle le samedi 25 à 17 heures au
palais des congrès place en france 75
francs est il possible qu'en dehors de
ce garçon il y ait rien d'intéressant à
voir cette année au printemps de bourges
bien sûr on relève dans cette liste ô
combien cosmopolite les noms de vieilles
célébrité du flon flon près pompidolien
comme charles trenet le fanon chantant
augustave malheurs du bal à jo munichois
ou ceux de quelques brammer moribond du
gospel des fifties comme ce pauvre
richard's qui lui non plus n'est pas
blanc blanc dans cette affaire
pour le reste rien le désert le néant la
boîte crânienne à la lan
dans ces conditions mesdames et
messieurs je vous le demande pourquoi
diable allait à bourges fait toujours
rire noble car enfin que nous propose ce
printemps pourri en occuper un prince un
sac très bien car enfin que nous propose
ce printemps pourri en dehors de ces
spectacles nauséabond des expositions
quelle exposition joly à la maison de la
culture seront exposés les instruments
traditionnels des musiciens du berry
qu'elle berry richard berry claude berri
jules berry strawberry quel instrument
du berry la bombarde à six trous la
flûte à pompe la cornemuse berruyères a
soufflé dans les chèvres le tronc
blanche est roi allons-nous amis
parisiens qui sommes tous débordés par
l'exigeante approté de nos tâches
urbaine qui nous conduisent chaque jour
au bord de l'infarctus et de
l'illégalité
allons-nous tous quittés brutalement
pour aller me restait biniou chez les
ploucs
et qu'est ce que c'est que ce village
des sponsors dont le dossier nous dit je
cite la nouvelle salle du festival
abritera l'accueil professionnel on y
trouvera tout nouvel espace le village
des sponsors lieu de rencontre
privilégié où se retrouveront aux
journalistes artistes partenaires du
festival
moi je veux bien mais qui nous dit que
des capotes seront bien distribué à
l'entrée
alors qu'à les faire à bourges dormir à
l'hôtel d'angleterre ou si j'en crois le
dépliant locales les chiens et les
handicapés physiques sont admis couché
entre un paraplégique à un cocker piètre
consolation n'est-il pas vrai pour qui
les lisent de vos films issus soeur de
betty
non non non non chers amis culture aux
dépressifs que seule la soif de sancerre
a éjaculé du bureau comme elle fait
sortir le loup du bois
non chers amis parasites venu vous
goinfrer aux frais de la branche dure du
groupe valdi ou la marive l'aller 4 par
l'icc arrive donc nous n'irons pas là
bas malgré le chant des sirènes qui lui
crie aux oreilles tel françois léotard
coursan la mer duras dans la rue
séraucourt au cul la vie à issel
printemps de bourges
[Musique]
mais non